Yo!
My whole life is dedicated to change.
(LAUGHING)
Hi, I am Ryan Lochte
and I'm an Olympic swimmer
and my favorite movie is Belly.
Belly is my favorite because it has
the best opening scene
and it's a straight gangster movie.
Like me.
After that movie, I feel alive,
really energized, my heart's beating,
and I feel like
I can conquer anything.
In a weird twisted way, the movie
Belly kind of has a purpose to it.
For me, I took from it is nothing
will stand in my way.
I will always try to achieve my goals
and there's nothing going to be--
That's going to stop me.
I'll keep going until I reach it.
I think that's the only way to live
as an Olympic athletic.
You have a goal, this goal is like
a highway, you can't stop off for gas
or anything.
You got to just keep going.
I'm Ryan Lochte and I love movies.